[Music]
on this monday night revised
recommendations on the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
why health canada now says people under
55 shouldn't get it
we need to take these precautionary
measures
what are the risks plus the reassurances
for those who already got the
astrazeneca shot
a closely watched trial begins mr
derrick shaman
betrayed this badge prosecutors lay out
their case against the former officer
charged with murdering
george floyd pinpointing the cause what
led to the crash of that snowbirds jet
in bc
and the ship show is over
it's all about physics the digging and
tugging it took to dislodge one of the
world's biggest container ships
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with more uncertainty about the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine which canada
is relying on to speed up the covet 19
vaccine rollout
the national advisory committee on
immunization now recommends
that the astrazeneca shot not be given
to people under the age of 55.
it says there is not enough data to be
certain the benefit outweighs
the risk in europe there are a few rare
but serious cases of blood clots in
people who have received the astrazeneca
vaccine
the european regulator investigated 25
cases of clotting out of roughly
20 million people who had been
vaccinated in the uk and eu
almost all the cases were in women under
55.
there have been no reports of similar
cases here in canada
federal officials are calling today's
change a precaution
until more studies are done on the
potential risks in canada
i think we're all on the same page that
this is something that's very rare
that we need to continue to follow it i
you know fully understand that this can
be
confusing but what i would say is again
precautionary approach
and and we'll move forward as we get
more information
astrazeneca is critical to canada's
vaccine rollout
1.5 million more doses are set to arrive
tomorrow from the u.s
there's already been so much evolving
advice about it and this latest change
will almost certainly damage
public confidence this morning ontario
health minister christine elliott who is
65 made a point of appearing on camera
to get the astrazeneca vaccine
she's urging people who are eligible to
take it
if it is offered to them there has been
a rollercoaster of advice though about
the astrazeneca vaccine
mike armstrong has our top story tonight
on the latest twist
and what it means for provincial rollout
plans
it wasn't an announcement any province
wanted to make but it came
one after another pei was the first to
pull astrazeneca
for people under the age of 55 saying
there may be a problem with blood clots
for those islanders who have been
vaccinated to date using astrazeneca
1680 of them i understand this news
would be
a little bit disturbing to hear this
this is still a good
vaccine it's still an effective vaccine
whether it was newfoundland and labrador
or manitoba the move came with a message
the astrazeneca pass
is just a precaution while we still
believe that
probably the benefits for all ages
outweigh the risks
i'm not comfortable with probably
the provinces were informed over the
weekend canada's national advisory
committee on immunization was
changing its recommendations the reason
a problem that was already known
appears to be worse than originally
believed much of europe suspended the
use of astrazeneca earlier this month
when the blood clotting issue was first
observed eventually most countries
resumed using it
determining the benefits outweighed the
risks at least 15 people died of a
syndrome health authorities are now
calling
vipid symptoms appeared 4 to 16 days
after vaccination
but it was rare about one in a million
now a german institute has determined
it's about one
in one hundred thousand cases identified
so far
have primarily been in women under the
age of 55
although cases in men have also been
reported
the idea of still using the astrazeneca
vaccine in older groups
may seem counterintuitive but in terms
of risk versus reward
it makes sense vipit is rarer in older
people
and they're at a much higher risk of
developing severe covet 19.
several european countries are already
reserving astrazeneca for older groups
sweden announced last thursday was only
going to use it on people
65 years and over mike armstrong global
news
montreal vaccine rollout really needs to
ramp up now not
slow down in a number of provinces cases
of highly contagious variants are
spreading fast
ontario recorded over 2000 new cases
today for the fifth straight day
at province's test positivity rate is
now over six percent
and it's estimated new variants account
for 68 percent
of all ontario cases travis danraj looks
at the race
to roll out vaccines
this is a scene canada is expecting to
see a lot more of this week
millions of new covid19 vaccine doses
arriving
3.3 million in the coming days are
expected
the largest single influx since the
start of the pandemic now it's
vaccination versus icu capacity so
that's a very real
real race so the more vaccines we get
the better we can protect
our population pasquale and maria
rizzuto got their first dose at this
toronto clinic and are eager to get
their second
hopefully we can get together with our
family and our grandkids
the roller coaster at canada's largest
amusement park is at a standstill
but in the parking lot at canada's
wonderland preparations are underway for
cars to roll through
and they'll go to one of the four buses
that we have
where they don't ever have to get out of
the car the immunizers will come to them
more than 11 percent of canadians have
received at least one dose of covid19
vaccine
in british columbia over 10 percent have
received at least one shot
in manitoba a little over eight percent
ontario approaching 12 percent
quebec nearly 15 percent and in nova
scotia
just six percent of the population have
been inoculated with one dose
we have nearly 400 000
vaccines sitting in freezers here in
ontario
and what we have not seen is an
efficient rollout
to deal with expiring doses and unused
supply some toronto hospitals created
standby lists for those not in priority
populations
the lists were quickly taken down though
online forms overloaded with people
signing up
if there's vaccine available at the end
of the day there's empty slots you can't
let that go unfilled
canada has come a long way back in
january worldwide we were 20th overall
when it comes to vaccines administered
but we've moved up on the list big time
in the last seven days we are now
fifth overall still it will likely take
months before enough canadians are
vaccinated
to return to some semblance of normalcy
the variance a wild card
in the equation travis stanrash global
news
british columbia has announced sweeping
new restrictions because of a
fast-growing surge in covid cases
including new variants in the last six
days we've seen
the start of exponential growth in new
cases
we've seen more hospitalizations and
more people requiring
critical care a circuit breaker is now
required
to break the chains of transmission in
our province
as of midnight tonight and for the next
three weeks indoor dining and
restaurants
nbc is suspended plans to reopen limited
indoor worship services has been paused
and the whistler black home ski resort
has been ordered to close
vaccine rollout is happening faster in
the u.s than canada about 30 percent of
americans have now received at least one
dose
but case numbers are rising there again
too as are hospitalizations
the director for the u.s centers for
disease control said today she has an
impending sense of doom
and she has one request don't act as if
the pandemic
is over we have so much to look forward
to
and so much reason for hope but right
now i'm scared
so i'm speaking today not necessarily as
your cdc director
not only as your cdc director but as a
wife as a mother
as a daughter to ask you to just please
hold on a little while longer
the world health organization is set to
reveal the findings of a joint
investigation into the origins of the
virus that causes covid19 that report is
set to be released tomorrow but some
media outlets have seen drafts
they reveal the who team believes the
novel coronavirus was most likely
transmitted from bats to humans via
another animal
it lists rabbits pangolins ferret
badgers and minks as possible
intermediaries
the investigators say it's extremely
unlikely the virus was leaked from the
institute of virology in wuhan
the chinese city where the first cases
were reported
got two justice systems in america one
for white america and one for black
americans
and we can't have that so i think today
is definitely the starting point
that is a nephew of george floyd in
minneapolis the trial of former
minneapolis
police officer derek chovin accused of
killing floyd got underway there today
prosecutors will argue that chauvin a
white police officer acted without any
regard for floyd's life when he knelt on
the 46 year old black man's neck
for nine minutes and 29 seconds during
an arrest last may
the defense will try to prove chauvin
did exactly what he was trained to do
the video of what happened ignited
protests around the world
we're going to show some of it in this
next story it could be disturbing
eric sorenson reports it is a damning
allegation against former minneapolis
police officer derek chovin
charged with murder and manslaughter in
the death of george floyd
mr derrick shaman betrayed this badge
prosecutors immediately produced
disturbing pictures showing chauvin with
his knee on floyd's neck
alleging the officer used excessive and
unreasonable force
putting a knee on his back for nine
minutes and 29
seconds was an eminently dangerous
activity
chauvin has pleaded not guilty the
defense suggesting police used
reasonable force against a large man
who was resisting arrest and with drugs
in his system
the evidence will show that mr floyd and
the officers began to struggle
three minneapolis police officers could
not overcome the strength of mr floyd
but prosecutors will call upon the
bystanders as eyewitnesses
the video they shot captured floyd
begging for help
bro it was their voices exhorting police
to let him breathe
you trapped him he's breathing right
there bro it is exceedingly hard to
watch
but that is what spurred unprecedented
outrage
american society could not look away not
this time
there were protests and violence over
repeated incidents of police brutality
the victims so frequently black the
police so infrequently held accountable
george floyd's family awaits justice
they say trust the system they want us
to trust this system
well this is your chance to show us
that we can trust you floyd's death and
other incidents spark protests around
the world
recognizing the reality of racial
injustice in canada
demonstrations that black lives matter
was a reckoning for this country as
it is a well problem we can't keep
quantifying well we aren't
murdering people to the extent that the
us
is so we can continue with our racism
it's not acceptable as the first
witnesses described what they saw that
day
the case has begun against a single
individual before the court
but for the family of george floyd and
many others american justice itself is
on trial
that would be a referendum on how far
america has come in its quest
for equality and justice for all the
trial is expected to take several weeks
eric sorensen global news toronto
we now know the cause of that deadly
crash of a snowbirds jet in british
columbia last may
the final report reveals a bird strike
caused an engine to fail
captain jennifer casey died after
ejecting from the plane at low altitude
she was part of the final leg of
operation inspiration a mission
intended to lift the spirits of
canadians during the pandemic
and while the report is careful not to
lay blame as our ottawa bureau chief
mercedes stevenson reports
it does make some significant
recommendations
operation inspiration turned tragic in
an instant
that sound a small bird being sucked
into the engine
triggering a chain of fatal events that
would kill captain jennifer casey
and severely injure the pilot captain
richard mcdougall
the strike resulted in an immediate loss
of thrust and power
captain mcdougall attempted what pilots
call a zoom and boom
an attempt to gain altitude and air
speed to try to recover the aircraft
or eject he was hoping to turn back to
the airport
and avoid crashing the jet into the
neighborhood below
absolutely that was the worst hand of
cards that the pilot could be dealt
by by far the final flight safety report
identifies the pilot's actions as a
factor
stating the climb caused the plane to
stall and lose altitude
there may have been a time early in the
incident that they could have gotten out
safely
that started to disappear when other
things
entered the pilot's mind captain
mcdougall and captain casey faced
a very difficult situation had very
little time to deal with it
casey and mcdougall had to eject outside
the safe parameters for the tudor plane
seats
that meant the parachutes weren't in the
conditions required to protect them
multiple air force sources told global
news there have been concerns on the
snowbirds and in the air force
about the ejection seats for years
especially after a 2016 crash
other jets modern ejection seats allow
for survival at a lower altitude
and in a broader range of conditions the
air force says
the planes are safe i would continue to
fly this aircraft again myself i've got
a full confidence in
in the seat when it's used within the
parameters and now with the additional
restrictions we put in place
we will guarantee that that aircraft
will always be within those parameters
a spokesperson for the department of
national defense said the military
is planning upgrades to the snowbirds
ejection seats that should be ruled out
for the 2021 flying season
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thank you
mourning the victims of a stabbing
rampage in north vancouver
coming up the growing memorial and new
details about the accused
police are still investigating that
stabbing in north vancouver b.c
two of the victims have now been
identified a woman in her 20s was killed
a teacher was also hurt and a single
mother of three suffered extensive and
life-changing injuries
robin gill is at the memorial for the
victims robin what is
the latest on the investigation well
investigators have interviewed more than
50 witnesses including the six survivors
and there appears to be no link to the
man who is now charged with
second-degree murder so it appears very
much that this was a random attack
and that is very unnerving for this
community and yet that has brought them
all together
just 24 hours ago there may be a handful
of bouquets
now it's about 10 feet deep
a somber memorial has grown in front of
what would normally be a hub of activity
in a north vancouver neighborhood people
felt compelled to silently grieve
it's our neighborhood it's our friends
our families and if it's not somebody we
know directly it's
somebody who we know or somebody our
friends know
on saturday shock when seven people were
stabbed
it started in the library and spilled
out into the street
one woman in her 20s is dead no one
expects to be confronted with violence
while going about their day in a civic
plaza
outside a library and just running their
errands
one of the survivors is shaloa clawson a
popular teacher in the community
who tried to stop the man using her
umbrella another
is suzanne till a single mother of three
who had extensive injuries
and may need more surgery and just
around the corner from the library
there are flowers for a woman named emma
the suspect is yanik bendago he injured
himself before being handcuffed
global news has obtained court documents
that show the 28-year-old was previously
charged with a series of assaults in
quebec
the paperwork shows bandalgo failed to
show up in court
and was to undergo a psychiatric
assessment but it kept getting delayed
at this gatnow home a neighbor confirms
bandalgo
once lived here back in bc the police
are trying to figure out
how he ended up on the west coast but
there was no relationship between him
and the woman killed we continue to
investigate the potential motive
behind the incident as well as the
suspect's background
and history in british columbia the
notes that are left at the crime scene
are asking those very same questions
the suspect was supposed to make a court
appearance today but he refused to leave
his cell and tonight we're learning
that he was also wanted on a warrant in
manitoba donna
all right robin gill in north vancouver
tonight thanks
ahead wild weather and a monstrous pile
up on an alberta highway
winter is over but southern alberta is
under a series of weather warnings
tonight blizzard conditions created
extremely dangerous driving conditions
and led
to a massive pileup on the trans-canada
highway between
50-70 vehicles collided near the town of
brooks about two hours east of calgary
the highway was shut down for several
hours visibility was terrible at the
time the road was treacherous and icy
causing
multiple semi-trucks to jackknife across
the highway
the heads of rogers and shaw
communications answered questions today
about their proposed 26 billion
plan to create canada's second largest
cellular and cable operator
they told a parliamentary committee they
need to be bigger to be more competitive
both companies say the deal which would
allow rogers to buy its rival
shaw communications and freedom mobile
will allow them to build the next
generation
5g network because i think this opens up
new doors and
with any capital investment you you have
an opportunity to drive
competition innovation new products and
services and really
i would say make that digital divide a
lot smaller for all of us
when pressed on divesting shaw's freedom
mobile both companies deferred to the
federal government's regulatory review
process
critics of the proposed rogers takeover
argue canada needs
more competitors in the industry not
fewer
next the good news flowing through the
suez canal
they did it the crew on board a dredger
in the suez canal are right to be
excited they helped free the ever given
that massive container ship
stuck for six days is now floating again
it is one of the world's biggest ships
and dislodging it was a gargantuan task
involving
digging tugging and a little help from
the moon
redmond shannon explains
[Music]
every given monday a maritime
celebration
echoed by the crews of more than 300
other ships
stuck in limbo for almost a week for six
days
dredgers and diggers removed tens of
thousands of tons of sand from around
the evergivens bough more than a dozen
tug boats
pushed and pulled to get the ship loose
eventually
relying on mother nature's help of a
spring tide
to float it free the recent arrival of
two heavy-duty tugboats
also proved key it's all about physics
and
most physical laws are not that
difficult you could say
but the trick is to make them work for
you and not against you and that's what
we did
one experienced sewers captain says
there are lessons for the industry to
learn about the canal bottleneck
definitely one of the things would be to
broaden the channel
maybe maybe even consider a second lane
as it is in the north section of the
canal
in the past 15 years the world's largest
container ships have doubled in size
and infrastructure has had to follow the
sizes
are a necessity for the trade and the
economies of scale
high winds are the prime suspect for the
ever givens grounding
but the exact cause is still unknown
this could be several years
before we actually understand and can
assess who's liable and how that
liability is going to get responded to
and the number of parties that might
actually want to take action
for the losses that they've incurred
could be it could be
incredible it could be a huge number
maritime insurance expert matthew yeshun
says
the immediate effect could be higher
prices in some countries
due to supply chain delays but in egypt
it's a mission accomplished for a job
that began with one
humble digger redmond shannon global
news london
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada are these ice floes near doraval
quebec a sign of spring
thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you